en el vídeo anterior queríamos encontrar
los valores propios de la matriz a que
era la matriz 1 2 4 3 y lo que hicimos
fue utilizar el hecho de que en general
lambda es un valor propio
un valor propio de una matriz
si sólo sigue si y sólo si
si sólo sigue el determinante de la
matriz lambda por la identidad menos a
es igual a cero utilizando esto vimos
que si la matriz a era esta matriz de
aquí los valores propios tenían que ser
o eran
5 y menos 1 estos son los únicos valores
propios que tiene esta matriz a ahora
bien todo esto fue con la suposición
suponiendo de que los vectores propios
suponiendo que los vectores propios
son distintos de cero en los vectores
propios
son
no lo sé
muy bien ahora esto solo es parte del
problema porque además de encontrar los
valores propios queremos encontrar los
vectores propios veamos en general cómo
podemos hacer eso si tenemos una matriz
y entonces encontrar los vectores
propios es encontrar los vectores b
tales que a por b sea igual a landa por
d
con distinto del vector ser esto lo
puede escribir como vector 0 debe ser
igual a lambda por b menos a por b
ahora bien si yo sustituye por la
identidad por b es decir si escribo esto
de la forma lambda por la identidad por
b menos a por b entonces tengo producto
de matrices por un vector menos una
matriz por un vector y noten que como
tengo la identidad por el vector b eso
sencillamente es el vector de estas dos
cosas son iguales así que esto es
legítimo y lo que puedo hacer ahora es
factorizar el vector b y escribir esto
como el producto lambda por la identidad
menos a
todo eso por el vector b todo esto de
aquí es una matriz y esto debe ser igual
al vector set
esto lo puedo decir del siguiente modo
para cualquier valor propio para
cualquier
cualquier valor
propio lambda voy a definir el espacio
propio en lambda
el ámbar es el espacio propio espacio
propio que corresponde al valor propio
lambda y lo que es es el conjunto de
vectores que satisfacen esta ecuación en
otras palabras el espacio propio son
todos los vectores propios que
corresponden al valor propio lambda y
entonces por definición como quiero que
satisfagan esta ecuación el espacio
propio que corresponde al valor lambda
es igual al espacio nulo oa la nulidad
de la matriz lambda por la identidad
menos
vamos a hacer el ejemplo de esta matriz
vamos a encontrar los vectores propios
de esta matriz a la matriz a tiene
valores propios 5 y menos 1 entonces
vamos a comenzar con lambda igual a 5
por definición el espacio propio
correspondiente al valor propio 5 es
igual al espacio nulo de la matriz cinco
veces la identidad 5 por 100
- la matriz a la matriz
es 124 3
así que eso es lo mismo que el espacio
nulo de la matriz 5 por 15 menos 14
45 por 0 0 - 2 - 2 5 por 0 0 - 4 - 4
y 5 x 15 32 positivos
así que estoy buscando el espacio nulo
anualidad de esta matriz y el espacio
nulo de una matriz es igual al espacio
nulo de la matriz reducida en su forma
escalonada por renglones así que puedo
cambiar esta matriz por la matriz
por la matriz vamos a cambiar el segundo
renglón por el segundo más el primero y
el primero se queda igual así que esta
es la matriz
4 - 2 - 44 es 02 más menos 2 es cero de
nuevo
y ahora solo voy a dividir la primera la
primera fila entre 4
y esto lo puede escribir entonces como
uno menos un medio
y estoy buscando el espacio nulo la
nulidad de esta matriz de aquí bien
cuánto vale esa nulidad pues estoy
buscando vectores b tales que la matriz
uno menos un medio
0 0 por el vector b sea igual al vector
0 que simplemente es el vector 0 0
pues vamos a escribir esto vamos a
escribirlo como sigue
puedo cambiar al vector b por un vector
variable con una serie de variables
qué van a hacer
v 1
de dos quiero encontrar las entradas del
vector b y esto tiene que ser igual a 0
pues si hago este producto de vectores
obtengo que uno por uno
más o menos un medio por b 2 es decir
menos un medio de 2 esto debe ser igual
a 0 la segunda entrada simplemente me
dirá que 0 es igual a cero así que no me
sirven nada de aquí puedo concluir que
b1 es igual a un medio de b 2
así que si pongo al b2 igual a t puede
escribir que el conjunto de vectores el
espacio propio correspondiente al vall
que en un valor propio 5 es igual a
todos los vectores de la forma
de uno de dos
iguales
un medio de té
donde esté
es un número real o dicho de otro modo
es 5
en 5 es igual al sub espacio vectorial
generado por el vector un medio 1
pueden checar que estos dos espacios son
el mismo así que este es el espacio
propio correspondiente al valor propio 5
y que hay ahora de el valor propio
lambda igual a menos 1 pues en este caso
el espacio propio que corresponde al
valor propio menos 1 es el espacio nulo
la nulidad de la matriz menos 1 por la
identidad es decir menos identidad menos
100 menos 1
- la matriz a que era la matriz 12 4 3
bien esto es lo mismo que el espacio
nulo de la matriz menos uno menos 13 -
20 menos 2 es menos 20 menos 46 menos 4
y menos uno menos 3 es menos 4
de nuevo puede llevar esta matriz a su
forma escalonada reducida
así que esta matriz se convierte en
vamos a dejar el primer renglón igual
menos 2 - 2 y cambiar el segundo renglón
por el segundo menos dos veces el
primero entonces tengo menos cuatro
menos menos dos por 2 menos 4 4 que es 0
y este segundo renglón se queda igual
perdón aquí de nuevo nos va a hacer eso
es a lo que me refería entonces estoy
buscando el espacio nulo de esta matriz
y ahora sólo por comodidad vamos a
dividir este primer renglón entre menos
2 de modo que obtengo 1100
muy bien
y quién es ese espacio nulo pues de
nueva cuenta
esto da cuenta lo que tengo que hacer es
encontrar los valores de b1 y b2
tales que este producto
viene el vector cero
y eso como lo hago pues simplemente toma
el producto y concluyó que b1 b2 es
igual a 0 eso sería el producto de este
renglón por este vector y de nuevo el
segundo renglón por este vector me da
simplemente 0 igual a cero así que de
aquí concluyó
v 1 es igual a menos de 2 y de nueva
cuenta si hago de 2
si bien 2 es igual a t entonces
entonces puede escribir
al espacio propio correspondiente a -1
como el conjunto de vectores
b1 b2
tales que
v 1 es igual a menos de 2 pero perdón
3 - t
y dedos este así que simplemente este
donde te está en los números reales o de
nuevo esto es lo mismo esto es lo mismo
el espacio generado por un espacio
vectorial generado por el vector menos 1
bien vamos a graficar esto para ver cómo
se ve
déjenme pongo ahí mi eje horizontal
y acá mi eje vertical
están un poco fuera el centro pero
servirán como se ve el espacio propio
correspondiente al valor 5 pues es el
sub espacio generado por el vector un
medio 1 así que si si esto es 1 esto es
entonces el vector un medio 1 se ve más
o menos algo así
algo así y el sub espacio que genera son
todos los múltiplos reales de este
vector es precisamente este conjunto acá
arriba y todos esos vectores están sobre
esta línea o están apuntando a puntos
en esta línea así que en realidad a este
valor propio le corresponden una
infinidad de vectores propios cualquier
elemento cualquier vector que apunte a
puntos en esta línea es un vector propio
que tiene por valor propio a 5 en otras
palabras cualquier vector que esté sobre
esta línea si le aplicó la
transformación representada por la
matriz
la matriz de acá arriba por esta matriz
entonces lo que me da
es 5 veces el vector original
ejemplo de este vector lo multiplicó por
5 y digamos una edad es el vector de ahí
así funciona la transformación en estos
vectores ahora que hay del espacio
propio correspondiente aa menos uno pues
ese es el generado por el vector menos 1
con el vector menos 11
se ve algo así así que su espacio propio
este espacio propio de más bien el
espacio propio del valor menos uno es la
recta generada por ese vector
todos los esos vectores todos
absolutamente todos los vectores que
están ahí o los vectores que apuntan a
esos puntos sobre esa línea son vectores
propios con valor propio menos 1
dando igual a menos 1 así que en esta
línea
lo que hace la transformación es
invierte la dirección este vector
amarillo este vector la enviaría a el
vector con la misma longitud pero
dirección contraria perdón sentido
contrario ok
así que ahora ya sé que es un valor
propio un vector propio un espacio
propio y quizás lo más importante es que
ya sé cómo encontrarlos y esto me da una
buena idea de cómo actúa la
transformación recuerden algo muy
importante es que a cualquier valor
propio cualquier valor propio le
corresponden una infinidad de vectores
propias generan todo un sub espacio
vectorial así que eso es algo muy
importante y muy interesante